hello and welcome to the Michaela
Peterson podcast this is episode number
seven I hope you're having a fantastic
week my week isn't so bad I'm still in
Belgrade in Serbia I'll be here for the
next few months it's quite nice actually
completely open very easy to get around
knowing only English people are friendly
a few things I've noticed that are kind
of interesting here everybody is in good
shape if you look at women's legs
walking by they're naturally strong from
all the walking they do here it's quite
a stark difference compared to America
or Canada even the second difference is
people have kids here it's not abnormal
for a group of mid to late 20 year olds
to all go out for coffee and hang out
and have all their little kids running
around them
it seems so natural it's so much better
than what I've seen in North America
honestly North America everyone's afraid
to have kids so if you have them and
you're young which I did I was 26 when I
had scarlet you're kind of ostracized
like all the people who have kids that
you make friends with our 35 and the
difference between 26 year old and a 35
year old is quite stark it's kind of
messed up anyway enough of me ranting
this episode I spoke with zubi zubi is
an independent rapper podcast host
author public speaker and creative
entrepreneur with over 300,000 followers
online he was born in England raised in
Saudi Arabia and is a graduate of Oxford
University so he's a fun guy if you
don't follow him on Twitter you should
he's pretty entertaining I don't think
I've ever met someone with neuroticism
as low as his nothing bugs him if I put
up something controversial on Twitter or
Instagram or whatever I get all anxious
and it bugs me at least a little bit I
can handle it but it bugs me he doesn't
get worked by anything remember to hit
subscribe if you want to hear more and
if you liked this episode please leave a
review if you didn't like it
don't screw up my four plus stars I'm
kidding enjoy the conversation and have
a good week
[Music]
Izu be welcome to my show thanks for
hopping on most welcome happy to be here
I thought we should start by giving
people a bit of a background who are you
what's your life story I'll delve into
that a little bit but I think people
like the gist of who you are yeah sure
so my name is zoobi I am a British
rapper author podcaster creative
entrepreneur fitness coach I do a lot I
do a lot of things it all started out
primarily with me being an artist and I
have sort of grown and expanded into a
few different fields over the past
couple of years so I've had an
interesting background I was born in the
UK I grew up in the Middle East in Saudi
Arabia I lived there for 19 years I went
to school there up until 5th grade
that's why I have this weird hybrid
American accent because I went to an
American / International School it
confuses everybody so most people who
meet me always think I'm American
whether they're British or American I
get literally man I've probably been
asked if I'm American literally several
hundred thousand times and that's I was
surprised as a bit confused watching
some of their interviews cuz like from
the UK and it's like no he's sounds like
pretty like the American with know like
accent kind of mmm-hmm yeah so it
confuses a lot of people my family
background is originally from Nigeria
and what else is interesting there's a
lot of interesting stuff I'm an Oxford
University graduate I studied computer
science there I worked in the corporate
world for a couple of years as a
management consultant whilst doing my
music stuff part-time and then since
2011
I've been full-time self-employed
started out like I said with just the
music and doing a lot of stuff with that
I've now released over eight projects
musically so five albums and three EPs
and twenty-something music videos so
I've been I've been on the grind for a
long time and it's weird because most
people who know me now only discovered
me in the past 12 to 14 months but
there's a whole big backstory behind all
of it
okay so I heard about you because of
your and I feel like this might be the
same for a number of people I heard of
you because of your deadlifting thing
that went viral so I wanted to talk
about that a little bit especially if
people don't know about it so how did
you get that idea and when was that what
happened exactly
okay so on the 28th of February 2019
I posted a nine second video of me doing
a two hundred and thirty kilo deadlift
so five hundred and something pounds and
the caption on it said something along
the lines of I keep hearing how there's
no how biological men have no strength
advantage over women in 2019 so watch me
destroy the British women's deadlift
record without trying psi identified as
a woman whilst lifting the weight so
don't be a bigot and I just tweeted this
time I just tweeted this like I tweeted
a lot of things I've got like 70
something thousand tweets I'll put out
there so I I just posted this thinking
yeah this will get some this will get a
few laughs amongst my audience and very
quickly I realized that I had I had
created some sort of defining internet
moment inadvertently so within I want to
say within 10 minutes it had over 10,000
views and then within an hour I think it
had like 50,000 views by the time I went
to bed that evening it was over 300,000
and just so weird
it went bananas like the numbers were
just I was allow Stella standing there
literally looking at my phone just like
what have I done here and I'll see who
was Reef and I was saying who was
retweeting it as well and it was just I
was just seeing it getting pinged it's
all these different different locations
it started going viral in the UK starts
getting picked up in the US I'm seeing
like Piers Morgan retweeted it and
cultura tweeted this
so in Surrey too it just big people and
then people in the world of sports it's
like it went viral in all these
different pockets and it went viral in
the sort of political Twitter it went
viral in sort of social media
it went viral in in the world of sports
it went viral in sort of the feminist
world right it went viral on all in all
of these different things that I'm not
even I'm a part of some of them but not
all of them and people were commented
seeing people commenting in different
languages Arabic Japanese Portuguese I
was like okay I don't even know what to
make of this and they just kept going
and going I mean when I tweeted it I had
19,000 followers on Twitter and within a
couple of weeks that had grown to 40,000
it just kill weird you just kept going
it went on for ages and then um when it
when that first wave we're starting to
calm down I wake up one morning and my
phone is going bananas I've got all
these whatsapp messages Twitter DM z--
everything people like Joel yo Joe Rogan
just mentioned you want to show your Joe
Rogan and I'm there like oh wait what
what and I watched the most recent
episode and he pulls it up and he's got
a whole section where he's doing Bryan
Callen and they're talking about the
tweet and he he follows me on Twitter
live on the show gives me a shout-out
and everything and then he DM me that
day and was just like dude that was
hilarious that's like the best thing
I've ever seen and it just kept going
and that gave me like a second wave so
so many hands in there Rogan of course
so that gave it a whole another wave and
it just kept going and I just kept
getting all these opportunities to do
interviews and lots of TV shows and
podcasts and media appearances and stuff
like that and it was it was just crazy
how it all happened
and I'm very grateful for all the work
that I did beforehand because that was a
catalyst so that was kind of like the
tip of the iceberg so people go viral on
Twitter all the time right you see it
you see these tweets with where tweets
go viral but the person behind it
doesn't because the person behind you
doesn't really have anything
particularly interesting that they've
created or that they're saying beyond
that one moment whereas in my case a lot
of people came along and there were like
oh oh this guy's interesting oh he's a
rapper oh he's got a podcast Oh
he's you know he's got some interesting
opinions on this on that so a lot of
people sort of discovered me through
that but then a lot of people stuck
around because they saw okay this isn't
just a sort of one-trick pony this is
someone who's interesting and who's got
something to add to the world in general
so I think that's why I was able to do a
lot more with it than just that one
moment that now happened over a year ago
yeah yeah because you're definitely just
growing and growing and growing mmm
which certainly doesn't happen to
everybody um you're an author what are
you an author of what have you written
yeah sure so I wrote and released my
first book last year called strong
advice zu B's guide to fitness for
everybody so it's a it's a concise
fitness book it's only about a hundred
pages started out just as an e-book and
then um I had a lot of people wanting
physical copies so I've now done I've
now done three runs of physical copies
which have all sold out now I don't have
any physical copies at the moment but I
will do another run in the future then
people wanted an audio book so when I
was in Nashville last year I recorded an
audio book version so it it started out
as um I mean I've been going to the gym
for longer than I've been rapping
I've been training since I was fifteen
so I was an overweight kid I got into
training primarily because when I went
to boarding school in the UK I started
to play rugby
so I mainly got into the gym because I
wanted to get stronger and fitter for
rugby and it's something I just fell in
love with and have became very
passionate about and very knowledgeable
about over time so I I kind of thought
well why don't I I get a lot of people
hitting me up for advice on this so why
don't I create something that I can
offer to people whether they're trying
to gain weight build muscle lose weight
burn fat get stronger break through a
plateau whatever it is I've learned all
of this stuff over the past 16 17 years
so why don't I take a couple of days why
don't I take some time out to create
something that can really help people
and that turned out to be one of the
best decisions that I've ever made
actually the book is totally
independently I mean it's sort about
2,000 copies now without even being on
Amazon
it's helped a lot of people got a lot of
positive reviews and it continues to
help people everyday so sometimes I kind
of kicked myself like man why didn't I
why didn't I write this thing earlier
but I think discipline takes a lot of
self-discipline to like say yeah [ __ ]
organize it yeah that's true that's true
and yeah so it's been um so so that's
the that's the one book I've written
thus far it's not going to be the not
going to be the last one but um yeah
it's helping a lot of people and I'm
really grateful for that because with
everything I do it's all about
inspiration I'm always trying to inspire
other people that's what my missions
about that's why I wanted to be a rapper
literally why I wanted to go into music
it wasn't for certainly wasn't for
financial reasons because I was making
more money in what I was doing
beforehand and so I kind of laugh when
people say oh he's doing this for the
money or doing that I'm like do you
don't even know what I was doing before
you know there are a lot of other things
I could be doing which would be a lot
more sort of stable and secure going
into music music for money probably
isn't the best idea from oh no no it's
not so I'm all about inspiring people
and trying to have a positive impact on
people in some way shape or form and
that's what I tried to do in my music
and it's now expanded beyond that and
that's cool I used to be very much I
view it like a house right I always we
used to want people to come through the
front door with the front door being my
music and then in 20 18 or so I kind of
had this realization where I was like
okay I can do music but there's other
things that I'm capable in and which I'm
interested in in which I can inspire
people in so I've also got Fitness I've
also got all the stuff that's going on
here in my brain I'm a good
conversationalist I'm good at public
speaking so why don't I do these other
things why don't I put it all on the
table and now it's like okay people can
come through the side door or the back
door or the front door or whatever I
don't really care as long as you're in
the zubi house then you are welcome okay
that's very cool that's very cool um how
do you decide so I'm gonna start asking
people just people who are doing well
for themselves kind of what their day
looks like like how much time do you
spend working versus your personal life
like what is your
morning 1 let's start with your morning
what is your morning look like when do
you get up what do you eat
right now it's everything's a little bit
screwed up because ok good like ideally
I know the quarantine is screwing
everybody on but ideally like what's
your schedule look like ok approximately
I normally wake up at 7:15 on the dot
I've gotten an extremely strong body
clock I haven't used an alarm for over a
decade but I just wake up at that time
literally within a minute
so I normally wake up yeah around 7:15
and then I drink water and go to the gym
and get dressed and go to the gym so I
train first thing and then I will ya
come back I'll normally break my fast
around it depends sometime between 10:30
and 12:00 normally so I'll go to the gym
come back get stuff get stuff set and
then yeah I'll just I just start working
on whatever my task that day is so
because I do a lot of things what I
normally do is I dedicate different days
to different things so for example this
is a this is a podcast day so today I've
been doing podcasts in interviews and
editing my own podcast and appearing on
other people so today's sort of
podcasting day and then I might have a
day where it's like ok I just want to
focus on I want to focus on selling my
book right I want to remind people oh
yeah I've got a book out there here's
the thing I might run a sale I might put
up some videos that help to promote it I
might just keep the conversation mainly
around that then I might have days where
it's like ok this is a music day I want
to sit and I get producer sending me
beats all the time right people who want
me to rap on their stuff people sending
me tracks so I'm just gonna I'm gonna
listen to all these tracks in my inbox
maybe I'll find some new beats maybe
I'll write a new song maybe I'll work on
a concept for a new video or a new idea
something like that so that's kind of
how I tend to split my days up and then
with me
the overlap between work play and
hobbies is very much it all crosses over
into each other so I don't really have
like I don't really take days off cuz
what I like doing in my downtime is my
career you know I enjoy making music I
enjoy writing songs I enjoy making
podcasts I enjoy having these
conversations I enjoy fitness and stuff
so there's not a I get a lot of people
ask me what I do in my downtime and it's
kind of like that's sort of the same
sort of the same I might not be as
intense you know sometimes I'm like okay
I'm really in work mode here but even
when I'm not I'm not a great I'm not
great at real at relaxing to be totally
honest with you I'm a very industrious
person and I get guilty quite quickly it
from superconscious yeah yeah makes me
very conscientious and extremely low in
neuroticism as well I'm kind of funny
I'm yeah that's not a nice combination
bottom 2% yeah yeah it's actually funny
you know your dad actually commented
several years ago on I took that
personality test and I did a YouTube
video on it and yeah actually he
actually commented on that video which
was which is funny so that's super cool
what were you okay okay I bet I could
guess some of that I mean
conscientiousness that was an easy one
if you're doing a whole bunch of things
and you're accomplishing them then high
in that open if you're doing a whole
bunch of things neuroticism is low
that's harder to guess that's nice
you're lucky about that my um my
volatility is incredibly high my
withdrawal is low so I'll go and do
things but I yell a lot um what about a
agreeable ah low low and agreeableness
pretty pretty well well pretty low
compared to the general population but
not that far off the male average okay
okay yeah 38 and go 38 percent 38 oh so
higher than a zoo okay there you go yeah
so let me try to remember off the top of
my head I think conscientiousness was
like a high 80s like 85 or something
neuroticism I remember was - that's so
nice
openness like 92 or something
agreeableness 38 extra highs and
extraversion like 75 yeah okay so much
something like that solid personality
yeah thank you so yeah it's quite it's
quite extreme I think I know the two
that were the craziest were yeah
withdrawal and volatility were super
duper low like - 3% and then
assertiveness was like 96 or something
and openness and intellect I think low
ceiling not - yeah yeah what what's
what's open is broken down into
intellect intellection noah and openness
so yeah - experience and intellect yeah
I think intellect was like 97 or
something stupidly high and then
openness to experience was like 80 or
something so yeah I didn't have very
many that were around the middle it was
kind of like out there or out there and
actually it was a great test to do
because it sort of explained a lot about
myself especially the super low
neuroticism one that really helped me to
understand my self very well because
I've had a lot of incidents in my
lifetime where that has sort of it's
generally a good thing for me but it can
manifest in certain ways where people
misunderstand me okay an example can you
can you give me an ax yeah sure so so I
by definition I am less impacted by
negative emotion than the vast majority
of people
like if you're at second percentile that
means if they're 100 this is the example
my dad uses if there are a hundred
people in a room 98% of them would be
more effective by affected by negative
emotion than you yeah so if the room is
on fire or we're on a sinking ship
I'm the guy you I will be the solid rock
who is chilling people out and I and I
am that person right when people freak
out when people are like getting angry
frustrated I'm always like the cool calm
collected one but the way it manifests
in a weird way sometimes is if something
bad happens then other people show their
emotions a lot more than I do which can
make people who don't know me think that
I don't care that makes sense so yeah so
for example like to take serious
examples I mean even in the face of
death right if somebody I know
dies a friend family member someone it
can to an outsider it can seem like I am
quite unaffected by it because I don't
outwardly display like the way I am
right now is we're talking I could be on
top of the world right now or I could be
down in the dumps right now and you
wouldn't really tell you wouldn't really
be able to tell because I'm just always
I'm just at that level right I just
don't fly just don't fluctuate a lot and
I've always I've always kind of been
like that so sometimes people think that
it can come across to some people like
I'm a little bit sort of cold or like oh
my god I'm just not I'm unaffected by
other things because other people will
be crying and you know totally
grief-stricken and stuff like that and
that's not really it's just not really
an emotional state that I get into not
because I'm trying to be a tough guy and
act like nothing affects me not not like
that
something can really really be on my
mind and I'm feeling it in my heart but
it just doesn't outwardly project him
that way so when I saw that 2% I was
kind of like okay that makes a lot of
sense and another way another thing one
of the
potential downsides of it maybe I think
the upsides are generally more than the
downsides but another one I've noticed
is that yeah I it means that I'm kind of
immune to say ends IAT and depression
this is good that would be webside yeah
yes that's an upside but it means that I
really struggle to even understand the
concepts yeah right when someone is
talking about being very depressed or
being made problems with anxiety and
stuff like that I can do my best and I
do do my best to empathize but I I can't
I can sympathize but I can't really
empathize because I've never in my life
felt depressed not even not even close
to it perhaps oh I felt sad but the
concept just it's it's a little bit
foreign to me because I can not directly
it's not like oh I felt that way before
I'm kind of like I've never feel that we
are I can I will I won't say this to
someone but my brain is kind of like
I'll just cheer up yeah what I mean I
just say well that's that's super normal
I made a um I made a youtube video a
while ago saying this is what it feels
like to be depressed because people
don't understand and if you haven't
experienced it you literally can't
understand so I likened it to like so
I'll try this with you to see if you've
experienced anything anything like this
but you might be so low in neuroticism
that even that won't make a difference
but it's like if you're really really in
love with somebody and they completely
break your heart
it's kind of like that feeling it's like
the feeling maybe maybe this if you're
walking down an area in a town that's
dangerous and you kind of feel like
you're gonna get jumped or something
it's kind of like that feeling yeah so
they're like feelings associated with it
but
yeah yeah I can I can sort of abstractly
get it but III don't think yeah I don't
know but I mean like I said that's not
in a it's not in itself it's not a bad
thing it's certainly a good thing that
it those things don't affect me
yeah but I guess what is good though is
I have a high level of self-awareness
that's why I'm even interested in doing
things like those personality tests
because I am aware of especially the
ones that are more extreme being aware
of those can help me to consciously make
an effort with certain things so if
something bad does happen I now go out
of my way to make it clear to people
that I care because well because my
default level isn't really to do that
and it's not because I don't care it
just like I said it doesn't manifest in
that way or similarly I'm extremely
assertive so I know I can very easily
dominate conversations if you've got a
room of eight people and everyone's
talking I can very easily kind of come
in there and just command the maybe as a
rapper there's probably a good thing
right as a performer yeah I could kind
of just come in there and not on purpose
sort of dominate the conversation a
little so I've learned to be aware of
that and to sort of pull back a little
and okay zoobi just shut up like just
listen and so yeah I think it's good too
I think that's why stuff like that it
makes it good to know your own
personality and know the way you're
wired especially in comparison to other
people so it's not just kind of raw
numbers it's like okay well compared to
other people I am like this so let me at
least be I'll use it to my advantage but
let me be aware of it yeah it took me it
took me years I don't know why it took
so long but it took years for me to
figure out that other people aren't
exactly the same as me it's like it's
the last two years and I'm 28 that have
been like why aren't you acting like I
would act as like Oh like you know the
50th percentile people I wanted to get
into your rap a little bit because I
know you made an album I saw a song a
long time ago you made an album called
perseverance mm-hm and I know you took
some inspiration
from some of what my dad's said yeah you
two go into a bit of that background
like you don't you don't swear in your
rapping right no I don't swear in real
life so I don't swear in my music okay
that's cool and it's in it is positive
compared to a lot of rap you hear yeah
most definitely most definitely I'm a
positive person I'm very I'm very much a
positive person I'm oh I'm what I called
I call myself an optimistic realist so
I'm I'm very real I'm very honest and
authentic and I don't try to sugarcoat
things and dance around things but at
the same time I'm very good at reframing
any situation in a positive way and I
I have very optimist I'm very optimistic
about my own life and I very much
believe in other people and their
capabilities and their potential which
is big reason why I like your your dad's
work because I very much feel the same
way as in everyone's just got this
potential in them and so many people are
let me let me take a step back I mean
even when it comes to my own music so
why did I decide to do my music
full-time it is because I know I've been
given certain talents and abilities and
a certain personality to trade and
everything and I'm like okay I've been
God has blessed me with these this
combination of factors and these
particular talents and skills etc and
most people cannot do a lot of the
things that I do so if I were to sit on
that potential in a religious sense even
to me that's almost like a sin you see
what I mean like if in my word if I were
to not use that to improve the world in
some way and I've just got these
abilities to do these things but instead
I choose to take a very comfortable
route and just sit in an office and do
something that is yeah maybe he's making
some difference but which isn't really
gonna impact the world in a tangible way
that I can notice I just kind of felt
like that would be squandering my own
potential so as someone who is sort of
consciously taken those steps for myself
to be honest from a from a relatively
young age from my early 20s I've always
wanted other people to do the same thing
so with my music and everything else
that I do hopefully people can gain some
of that so in terms of that song itself
perseverance um yeah that was funny I
think I actually wrote that song a
couple of weeks before I went to the
when when did I write that song I think
yeah I had written I had read 12 rules
for life and I'm trying to remember the
exact lyric now it's really hard for me
to remember my lyrics unless I start
from the beginning
right it's hard for me to like jump
halfway through a verse I have I have
that with piano songs okay start in the
middle yeah yeah I'm trying to actually
think of the lyrics
[Music]
you're always talking evil in your raps
and I'm trying to put my meanings on the
map I gave you 12 roots for life and
kept my room clean I'm the Jordan
Peterson a frat yeah that's the lyric
that's lyric that is so cool yeah thank
you is that lyric really stuck it's so
funny I've been asked about that in so
many interviews I've even had articles
come out where that that's kind of the
quote the Jordan Peterson have rap sort
of things so it's kind of amusing how
that um how that stuck so yeah it was
just a little bit of wordplay but also
wanting to yeah give it give a little
shout-out to someone who I think is cool
and who I think is doing good good stuff
in the world
so Wow Wow yeah that's my that's my
listen that's why I did that but
generally I mean like I said in my music
it's really about the same thing I try
to be across the board well I don't try
to be I just I just
hopefully I just am but it's about
chasing your dreams fulfilling your
potential being honest telling the truth
being authentic a lot of rappers like to
say keep it real keep it real and real
is a such an overused term in hip-hop
because so much of hip-hop is so fake
but people who are always talking about
keeping it real
and so with me I I take that honestly
that's why people ask me well why don't
you swear in your music because I don't
swear in real life
why would I suddenly why would I
suddenly go into the studio and I'm a
whole different person with a whole
different personality and a whole
different background that's like nah I
am zubi I'm an I'm a you know well
raised Oxford graduate who happens to
rap and has a certain message to put out
here I'm not gonna start rapping about
how yeah you know I'll grow up in the
streets and I was in the ghetto and I
was selling crack and I've been shooting
bales like come on man that would be the
fakest thing in the world and there's
already so much negativity out there in
the world and within the genre why would
I want to add to that yeah we like the
world needs the counterbalance and yeah
I try to be that to some degree wow
that's that's great that's fantastic
okay in regards to your neuroticism then
when this tweet you made went viral I'm
sure I'm sure there you got a hell of a
lot of negative press associated with
that as well
so did that like how did that affect you
did it bother you at all or were you
just like awesome well it didn't really
work because I'd already checkmated
anyone who wanted to say something like
that because no one could criticize that
say say you had someone who really
believes in this gender ideology thing
okay mm-hmm they can't criticize it
without being a hypocrite they have to
have no leg to stand on because that was
the point of the tweet I just I was like
okay you know what I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna argue against this I'm gonna just
take your logic
and become the British woman's death of
champion and if you say that I am NOT
that that that's not legitimate or you
say that I'm not a woman by your own
very definition you are now the transfer
yeah right you you've been you've been
telling everybody for all these years
that a woman is anyone who identifies as
a woman and I've just told you I
identify as a woman you have no evidence
or proof or anything that I'm not based
on your own logic so you there isn't
there's nothing to say there's nothing
to criticize people can say oh he's
making fun of this but it's like well
how do you know that I could say that
about anyone who claims to be a woman or
claims to be a man or whatever if it
doesn't match their biological sex and I
could say well they're just there
they're there make G see what I mean so
that wasn't really fair enough yeah and
that would that did frustrate a lot of
people because I you could tell they
kind of wanted to they wanted to be
offended but they couldn't kind of work
out why they're like this is offensive
somehow I don't I don't like this but I
don't really know I don't really know
why because if they say something yeah
it's so firstly I want to say that
nineteen ninety-eight percent of it was
positive 98 percent of the feedback was
positive and this includes people before
the funniest thing is I don't think
there were a couple of people who tried
to be offended on
trans people's behalf if that makes
sense yeah you get a lot of oh yeah
totally make sense who want to be ad
yeah but every message I got from an
actual trans person maybe with like one
or two exceptions was dude that was
hilarious I got so many messages that
guys just from people who were like yeah
I'm actually trans and this is freakin
funny yeah so that actually made it made
it funnier because it was just like well
okay you can't be more offended than
supposed the supposed Vidya am you see
what I mean yeah and people try to do
this a lot and it's like okay well if
they really have a problem with it then
certain people can speak but yeah dad
had exactly like dad had exactly
experienced it was like we're all the
people that I'm supposedly offending
exam only people who are offended on
their behalf yeah which is so not useful
yeah and if you think of it I mean the
tweet itself it didn't really and he
said it's a bit like the whole thing
your dad got into the bill c16 thing is
it didn't even really have anything to
do with trans people the the point being
made is that there are biological
differences between men and women so
therefore having biological men complete
Pete against biological women is stupid
and everyone knows this no one no one is
saying it but everyone everyone knows
this it's obvious so in video format I
just showed people why that is the case
because Amy and I think it was extra
funny because I'm not a I'm a strong
dude but I'm not a professional power
lifter Yeah right I'm not I don't even
compete so the fact that I can just like
stroll into the gym and obliterate the
record because the way I lifted in the
video wasn't even close to my maximum
that's why in the video like I'm not
straining it's not hard I could have
lifted it five times so it's just like
okay done and that's that's kind of it
so that does more than any intellectual
you see people always making these these
hyper intellectual academic arguments
for this situation which which I can do
but it's so basic that you even have to
have a conversation about it right yeah
yeah okay so I would put you probably in
the
category now if you had to categorize
yourself in the IDW group kind of that's
where your pop I think that's where your
popular online just from what I've seen
on Twitter so how do you stop yourself
and this is a question I got I asked my
audience like if anyone had questions
for zubi and one of the questions was
how do you stop yourself from being
ideologically possessed well I don't
have an ideology
what if someone were to yeah I don't
know certainly certainly but what if
someone were to put you in the IDW crew
and I like most people in the IDW crew
but I do find that some voices and not
yours but some voices kind of just echo
other people's beliefs in that crew so
what do you do as a person just to keep
your head and your mind focused on like
I guess staying truthful without being
influenced particularly on Twitter by
other people you follow and everything
well firstly I make sure that I piss
everybody off a little bit it's like oh
you think you're my friend no no no no
like here's something annoying about you
yeah yeah well I don't not even when I
say that I don't even mean talking about
any individual in fact that's something
I very much don't do I don't talk about
individuals on Twitter yeah I don't
target individual people I talk about
ideas generally but yeah if I know that
I occasionally maybe once a month I will
post something normally on Twitter which
I know is going to upset I don't know I
want to I hopefully have at least a
couple of tweets which everybody has a
problem with right no matter where you
are so for example I've got um you know
a lot of a lot of my American followers
are Trump fans not all of them not all
of them at all in fact but a lot of them
are so sometimes I mean one of the
funniest tweets I had was where I
complimented both Trump and Obama in the
same tweet
and then looking at the fallout from
that one was just kind of like oh my
gosh because then it was like yeah the
super super pro mega anti-obama people
were like oh come on zu be like you
can't say anything I was like it's why I
said you know like and and I didn't make
it up it was like no this is my opinion
I think I think I said something like
both Trump and Obama are very iconic US
presidents in their own way I said
something along those lines
okay which which is true yeah but people
are always gonna remember Obama he was
the first use the first black president
no.1 yeah that's gonna that's gonna go
down in history people are gonna
remember Trump whether you like him or
dislike him you can't deny that he is
and he's a force definitely I got yeah
he's iconic like in history in the
future people are gonna be looking back
and being like you know like this
president this is a thing that happened
this was crazy even the people who don't
like him they'll be like man like like
how how is this still a thing yeah well
I know how it's a thing but yeah
regardless so yeah I'll do that or I'll
say something um I don't know I'll say
something super positive about Saudi
Arabia people don't like that and what
was what variants like there I do want
to get into that a little bit yeah sure
it was fantastic
and where did you work where did you
live I lived in the East so um the city
that the closest city that people may
know of would be like Dharan or Al
Khobar so in the east
so um excuse me yeah so my dad's a
medical doctor so we moved out there
literally when I was a baby and my mom
worked there as well firstly as a
journalist and then working kind of in
the in the community information center
but yeah I mean I lived in Saudi for 19
years so I had a I had a great
experience there I had a great
experience there are lots of my lots of
my friends to this day are people who I
grew up with out there it's a very it's
a very interesting country first of all
but it's also a very misunderstood
country in many ways because
it's weird because most people don't
have strong opinions on most countries
right so if you ask someone up what do
you think of Estonia what do you think
of Georgia what do you think of
Liechtenstein what do you think of I
don't know of Argentina most people
don't have strong opinions but everybody
everybody feels entitled to have a super
strong opinion about Saudi Arabia and
oftentimes they're not informed by very
much sometimes there might be kernels of
truth just like there's this kernels of
truth to most things but it's weird how
strongly and emotionally people say
certain things oftentimes which are
totally incorrect by the way and it's
yeah it's it's a weird one so I've had
um I mean I yeah I've caught a lot of
flack I've caught a lot of flack
actually online recently for doing for
saying positive things about Saudi
Arabia or even for how doing a podcast
with someone from there cuz because I
was getting all of this I was you know
what because so many people kept saying
look you are an expat your experience is
gonna be totally different from someone
who's actually from there so I tweeted
out like hey I know I've got people who
follow me from Saudi Arabia I'd love to
have a couple of you on my podcast and
come and give your own perspective and I
did and a lot of people did who the
people who actually listened to that
podcast really enjoyed it and we're like
oh wow okay that's different from what I
thought and then I had other people who
didn't even bother to listen to it and
they just kind of kept going on and on
and on and yeah it kind of gets tiring
but circling all the way background to
answer your original question about how
do I avoid ideological possession is by
being being on being authentic really
being authentic there's no problem with
being influenced we're all always being
influenced by things and that's fine but
I do very much think for myself and I
have my own and I'm just I'm very open
I'm very honest I I don't put every
single thought I have out there but I
put a lot of them and I'm open to I'm
open to feedback I'm open to different
thoughts quite often I just like to
spark a conversation and sit back and
read the replies
that's kind of how I use Twitter
sometimes these days especially because
I've got so many followers now that yes
replies like that has to be what my
version of hell would be would be just
reading Twitter look lies oh I can't
like it no I can't yeah it's crazy and
that's something I'm adjusting to
because the first 10 years I was on
Twitter I had less than 20,000 followers
so it took me to me 10 years to get to
20,000 and then to go from 20,000 to 220
something thousand that just took 12
months so I'm still adjusting to it and
Twitter doesn't have any filters that's
the thing it doesn't have any filters
besides the verified thing so it's yeah
it's weird cuz what's happened is it's
just turned into a forum basically so my
Twitter is pretty much just a forum so
even if I look at my mentions 80% of
them aren't directed to me it's just
people having conversations yeah under a
conversation that I sparked and that's
cool that's cool
I'm sort of still in that stage of just
learning how to learning how to use it
but I just try to always stay stay
grounded stay me and stay honest and to
be honest I've got I've got a great
circle of people I've got a wonderful
family I've got a lot of great friends
and everything so if I don't think this
will ever happen to me because
everything actually has been very
gradual but if I ever did reach a stage
where it was like okay I'm becoming very
ungrounded and untethered from reality
or whatever I know that there are a lot
of people around me who would help to
bring me back to the center and keep my
feet sort of planted on the ground so I
don't really worry about that too much
okay that's good um I'm gonna ask you a
little bit about diet because a lot of
people listening to me I've I don't know
various problems with these diet to
treat so I'm wondering what your opinion
is on diet given the fact that you're
pretty into fitness what do you do for
yourself do you do anything I'm not a
big fan of unless it's necessary I'm not
a big fan of
[Music]
strict diets in terms of eliminating
entire food groups let's say so of
course you have I know of course you
promote the carnivore diet and I know
that that has worked very specifically
for you and you've had specific health
issues that it's helped to alleviate and
that makes sense but you've got so
you've kind of got a lot of different
camps people just like people get tribal
over everything oh yeah and people now
are getting tribal over diets so on one
hand you've got the the carnivore
movement on the other hand you've got
the vegan plant-based movement and then
you've got the sort of paleo and the
keto and all these things and I'm just
kind of like hey are almost ripe oh yeah
and I'm kind of like I'm just an
omnivore like I'm not a grains I'm like
I eat what all of you eat okay I just
don't exclude anything so when you get
people like no grain no bread no potato
I'm like no I eat all that and then you
got people like no meat no - no I eat
that yeah for me for me personally I I'm
very much I just practice flexible
dieting so I care more about overall
caloric intake and macronutrients then I
found that I don't need to be any more
um and that much more refined than that
obviously I generally try to eat good
wholesome nutritious foods I don't sit
there eating Snickers and harrybo all
day and stuff so I add 80 90 % of the
stuff I eat would be clean shall we say
but every day I eat sugar every day I
eat sweet things every day I don't
people are often shocked like I eat ice
cream I eat cookies like I don't um and
I've got a pretty large caloric it means
for me to maintain my weight when I'm
being normally active it takes about
3,200 calories or so so I've got quite a
buffer that I can kind of get away with
you know I can eat like 2600 calories of
good wholesome nutritious food and then
if I
have 500 600 calories of stuff that's a
little bit more borderline I've found
that it doesn't really affect me and
it's not good for me
psychologically either to get to obsess
over it too much when I was a teenager I
used to actually a lot more strict cuz I
used to kind of when I first started out
I used to follow like the hardcore
bodybuilding bro stuff and just be like
okay I must eat six meals a day and each
one must have this many grams of protein
and I can't go catabolic and I must do
this and let's do that and yeah I could
make some progress on it cuz I was still
doing things right but as I've gotten
older and wiser I've learned to just do
what works for me and I'm not in I'm not
a big fan of the one-size-fits-all thing
in general and I don't get why people
it's why I think people getting tribal
over diets is kind of silly because I'm
like look do what if it works for you
I'm not going to tell you to stop doing
it right if you just eat if you
completely eliminate dairy and meat and
all that and you go 100% plant-based and
you feel great and you're healthy and
your blood work is good and your
performance is good I'm not gonna come
up to you and tell you oh your diet is
your diet is crap this is what you
should do you should eat more like me
similarly if you just eat steak and
water and that works for you I don't
want to just eat steak I don't want to
see if it works for you I'm not gonna be
like oh no no you're doing it you're
doing it all wrong you need to eat more
grains you need to have some honey in
your diet you need to have this you
don't know if it works for you you know
there are certain there are certain
rules about our body and certain sort of
scientific laws which apply to everyone
but beyond that we're all we're all
individuals we're all individuals so
what works for one person is not always
gonna be the same thing that works for
other people that I think it's kinda
silly to assume that it would be because
we already know that that's not that
that's not the case
I have seen people
seeing people go on vegan diets and
thrive and I've seen people go on vegan
diets and it's clearly clearly bad for
them by it's not even it's not even
debatable right they just their health
goes to crap they're tired they're
they're just not they don't they don't
even look right and so with someone like
that I don't know I don't know all the
nitty-gritty of why that might be but
it's clear that some people yeah some
people can do better on that whereas
other people don't you know that's
someone like that they do that and then
oh they start eating some beef and some
chicken again and suddenly they look
better they feel better
the hair looks better their skin looks
better so yeah beyond any ethical
reasons it's like yes you don't go with
that so I'm not um I'm not dogmatic with
my own diet and I'm not a big fan of
dogmatism when it comes to nutrition in
general I would firstly I'm kind of like
most people eat terribly so so let's
first get to the stage before trying to
get everyone to go keto or go carnivore
go like let's try to get people to just
eat decently and not live on junk food
and fast food right now that would be a
great first step before we try to get
people to totally cut out grain or seed
oils or this or that
that's kind of my opinion yeah okay
fair enough eat Whole Foods rather than
yeah food that your ancestors would
recognize primarily yeah I think there's
a good role too I'm jealous of your
ability to eat Snickers bars without
going car we'll trade I'll send you some
some steaks you actually know actually
that's not a good deal is it an assassin
using steak seal for you yeah I heard
that you're considering moving to the
States
is that a thing oh wow I just posted
that like recently didn't I I was
looking at the comments and the comments
are telling me why I think I need to do
it because everybody seems to want me to
so yeah I'm not I've been um to be
honest I've been toying with the idea
for many years and then after my nine
week trip last year it became
it became pretty obvious to me that um
that's where the majority of my audience
is I mean that is that is where most my
audience is if whether I'm looking at my
book sales for my merchandise sales or
my Spotify numbers or my YouTube this
top country USA by a large margin and
and it hasn't always been that way
that started to shift around 2018 so it
seems like a lot of what I'm doing does
resonate more with an American audience
than it does with a British one or one
anywhere else and I can think of quite a
few reasons why that may be but um yeah
there's a there's a lot of process you
can just go to America and stay there
obviously so there's a lot of process
but um it seems to be becoming more and
more likely as time goes on there's a
lot of stuff that is pulling me in that
direction and it seems like at a minimum
I certainly need to be spending a lot
more time out there cool
what did you think of you were in LA me
I know you traveled around America but
like what did you think of LA
particularly LA is interesting at least
very interesting it's a unique city
firstly when I was there I felt like I
was in Grand Theft Auto because I know
they modeled the city in the game after
LA but it's crazy how well they captured
the vibe the weather is amazing I really
like the weather I like some aspects of
the city I don't think it's somewhere I
would ever want to live it's a place
that there are a lot of cities that I
like to visit but I don't want to live
in them
la New York London Paris not interested
in living in any of those cities but I
like the vibe there a lot yeah la is
weird though
la is um it's kind of hard to describe I
really like I really like some aspects
of it but some stuff is just too weird
it doesn't totally fit my it doesn't
totally fit my vibe
it doesn't totally fit my vibe I felt
more at home in like Texas in general so
Alison Austin and I went to Austin
Dallas and Fort Worth and all three of
those cities I was like I could live
here
well they're more I I kind of get what
you're saying I've been to I haven't
been to Dallas but I've been to Mort
Worth and Austin and it's a bit more
like people aren't putting on an act I
guess yeah it's more real I mean it's
funny
did you know something really
interesting and I made this observation
I think I did post something about it on
social media which is that the sort of
southern American states and what people
call sort of flyover country
I have always since a child I've always
found that I get on particularly well
from people from those states even when
I lived in Saudi Arabia there were lots
of families from Texas and Texas and
Arizona and places like that and I
always found some kind of affinity with
them and oddly I think that there's a
large crossover in culture between
Nigerians and people in Middle America
and southern and the southern most
states in the USA and it's also
interesting because I think the state
with the most Nigerians in it in the
u.s. is Texas so many lots of Nigeria
has live in Texas yeah a lot of
Nigerians live in Texas and even the
weather the people the religious values
a lot of the stuff actually aligns with
Nigerian culture which is which is weird
I think I made a joke or something like
I think um I heard some joke about it
when God was like making humans he sort
of made people from Texas and Nigeria
sort of out of the same clay and sort of
put them in different totally different
locations but so there's this sort of
bond or something but um yeah it is
something I've noticed like I felt a lot
more at home there and more comfortable
there in certain ways than I do then I
did in DC or New York or LA or San
Francisco the places I felt most likey I
could live here were yeah the three
Texan cities that I went to and then
also like Nashville they just - well I
want to go to Nashville yeah there's
something there's something there that
the vibe just um it's more on my
wavelength I don't really know how to
describe it but I just kind of felt more
like yeah I like I belong here more I
feel I don't feel I don't feel like such
a guest I've never been here before in
LA I felt like a guest San Francisco I
felt like a guest I got to Austin I got
to Dallas I was like okay yeah I haven't
been here before
but I kind of feel very welcome yeah I
know exactly what you mean that's an
important feeling people should pay
attention to that yeah yeah
the fact that there's even little things
I don't know there's churches everywhere
and lots of billboards promoting God and
stuff and I like that I am a Christian
yeah okay and um yeah and I don't know
in LA it was felt like the AH
LA's yeah yeah it's just the opposite
you know what I mean so they give me it
gives me a kind of weird vibe I'm kind
of like yeah everything is entertainment
and Hollywood and it's it's very I don't
know it's it's one part of it is kind of
cool but another part of it is kind of
like just weird and people smoking weed
everywhere and like advert seeing
billboards for cannabis all over the
place and not that I'm like I mean I
don't I don't smoke myself I don't but
I'm not even like opposed to people
doing that but it's just weird I'm in
one state I'm in one city and I'm seeing
billboards for cannabis dispensaries and
TV shows and comedy shows some of which
are look pretty degenerate and then I'm
I go to Texas and I'm seeing billboards
for this church and churches and
shooting ranges and fast food I don't
know yeah it's just a weird vibe and
that was one of the coolest parts though
about the trip was going to I went to
ten different cities and I spent a
decent amount of time in each one and
all of them are pretty different like I
went to Atlanta as well I spent two
weeks in Atlanta and Atlanta is totally
different from the others and then I
went to DC and that was really different
Nashville was different New York was
different so it was a good way to a
minute States a few times before but
most of those cities I hadn't been to
before so it was really cool kind of
getting that opportunity to not just go
to one place and get that vibe but to
travel around meet different people I
had a lot of conversations with people I
did meet ups in different cities and
yeah it was a it was dope so we'll see
we'll see where that goes in the future
yeah that's cool what was your what was
your favorite City do you have a
favorite ooh
it's it's hard to say it's hard to say
in terms of opportunities Elia was the
best yeah yeah to fight that - yeah in
terms of opportunities Elia was the best
and also in terms of whether LA was the
best in terms of hmm
I could like live here and have a family
in the future that would probably be
mm-hmm Dallas or Nashville well I really
did like Atlanta to Atlanta's very much
as a rapper as a hip-hop artist that was
kind of like okay I can see why so many
rappers come out of the city because it
just has has a very certain vibe to it
and interestingly I think I think
Atlanta is probably the only I think
Atlanta is a black majority city I
believe demographically but I think it's
the only black majority city I've been
to in the Western world
if I think about it yeah I haven't which
I haven't been around that much I need
to do one of those trips first yeah yeah
so that in itself sort of gives it a
little bit of a different vibe in a way
so I was kind of like okay this is this
is interesting because I'm coming from
like Fort Worth and now I'm here in
Atlanta and the vibe yeah the vibe is
it's itchy it's hard to sort of
articulate but it's culturally it's it's
different the vibe is good the vibe is
kind of different so yeah I'd maybe so
those ones were probably my favorite
they all have their kind of pros and
cons and things I like and dislike about
all of them like New York City is cool I
like visiting in New York City there's
no way on earth I would ever want to
live there yeah me neither
yeah like I can get why people like it
but no it's just I know myself and I'm
not a fan of huge cities actually once
you're past about a million people I
think it's too many
there's too many in lighting its to me
yeah I think it's too many in one place
I just like I'm not a huge fan of London
every time I'm in London again I like to
visit and I lived there for three years
but it's too many people in one place
just too many people in one place when
I'm in London I just feel like it's too
many people here in New York City yeah
would you would you want to live there I
haven't been to London but I like it
honto New York like it depends
the only thing I really don't like about
New York is in the winter when you're
walking down the streets it's like
you're at the bottom of a cliff all the
time and everything is dark it's more of
a light thing if I could live in a big
city with lots of light that I would do
that yeah yeah and then of course in big
cities everything's super expensive and
overpriced and you get an e then and
then you kind of get the big city
attitude which is oh yeah the big city
attitude sucks yeah I don't know I just
feel like the whole tight everybody
there's a bunch of opportunity though
yeah there is and that's and that's why
people and that's why people are there
so it draws a certain type of person and
I can understand that and someone who's
entrepreneurial and has that hustle in
them and whatever I get that and I like
it to a degree but I also like to be
able to get away from it and not have to
deal with it all the time for example I
mean in London I mean where I live like
my
can just my I've got my own parking
space my car's parked there I can just I
can just drive wherever I want I can
park easy to find parking I don't have
to deal with insane traffic I don't have
to pay in London for me to just drive
into central London like I need to pay
what twenty pounds a day just to drive
in there you've got all that you've got
the emission charges you've got the
congestion charges if you want to park
parking for the day in London might be
like thirty pounds just to park your car
it's just it's just a hassle if I want
to take why not when you could not do
that yeah if I want to take the train
just the train might be like 50 pounds
which is crazy I mean I don't even look
that far away I mean for a less than an
two hour journey
fifty pounds and then the Underground's
gonna cut it's just I don't know
everything is just more hassle and
stress than it needs to be and if I'm
looking towards the future I'm not there
yet but one day I will be married and I
will have a family and raising future
children and a city like that just isn't
isn't viable to me for a whole bunch of
different reasons so it was cool living
in London when I was like when did I
live in London between the ages of 20
and 23 or so and it was kind of cool at
that time but um now I wouldn't want to
go back and yeah I just wouldn't I
wouldn't see myself living living
somewhere like that again there are
other cities that there are other
options I just think that yeah yeah the
the UK is a bit weird because it's so
London centric but um there are plenty
of cities in the UK that I prefer to
London hmm how old are you just out of
curiosity I'm 33 okay
family eventually you should do it kids
are awesome oh yeah yeah yeah I often
joke I mean I've told people on Twitter
I want to have 50 kids yeah yeah it
upsets all the right people you have to
get started then I know it's okay I've
got the easier part right you've got
lots of time anyway whatever I've got
the male privilege on this one yeah
definitely I'm from I'm from a big
family so maybe that's yeah how big is
your family immediate I so I have four
siblings my dad is one of 11 my mom is
one of seven I think I've got nine
nieces and nephews too so if like if all
of our immediate family including the
nieces nephews and in-laws are around
it's like I don't know 20 20 something
of us that's so fun yeah yeah it's
awesome
I love it we've got a really close
family and then my extended family is
huge I've got I think like fifty first
cousins or so Wow yeah and they've all
got kids so they were like a clan like
we've got there are a lot of us and
there are a lot of us but it's really
nice that is really nice
okay so where can people find you or do
you direct people awesome if you want to
follow me on a day to day basics sorry
day-to-day basis Twitter is the best
which is at zoobi music I'm also at the
same handle on everything so Instagram
YouTube Facebook Twitter all of them are
at zoobi music zu be why music and if
you want to check out my music or my
podcast just search for my name
zu be on whatever you use iTunes YouTube
Spotify whatever you'll find me okay wow
thank you very much for coming on that
was a fun conversation good luck with
everything be reading your tweets
messaging you occasionally okay cool
okay talk to you later bye
[Music]
you